melissa is in gainesville florida
hi melissa welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave thank you um i'm saving up cash
to buy a home in cash and i opened a
second bank account a high-yield
interest
savings account um and when i got to 250
000
i realized i would no longer be fdic
insured
so i opened a third banking account to
continue saving cash
and my question is when you're actually
buying
larger properties and cash especially if
i want to start investing in real estate
in the future
where do you actually keep all of this
money to keep it fdic
insured and safe uh you don't
mind my money that i say for real estate
is not fdic insured it's in mutual funds
okay i buy just a uh s p 500 index fund
that i'm going to hold where i'm
throwing money to pile it up for real
estate
and uh i can come back and get it after
a year and i'll have no taxes on the
game or i have a capital gain tax on the
gain is all
and um if you leave it alone at least a
year you're gonna it'll save you on
taxes and you'll make more on it than
you would in a stupid bank anyway
but fdic insurance is 250 000 per
depositor per bank if you're married
that's 500 000.
there's two deposits i'm not married i'm
single that's fine that's fine
then you can have you know you have
three banks and have 750 000
but you're still only making one one
eight or one and a quarter or something
on your money over there
uh and so if you want it to be super
safe like that you're surrendering any
rates of return
but i don't think anything at all about
throwing a million dollars into an s p
500 that's a very stable account
it's as stable as the american economy
is
it could go it could go down in value
but the chances of me losing it
all is almost zero if the s
p 500 becomes worth zero the american
the united states of america has
collapsed
mathematically it is so that means the
top 500 largest companies on the stock
market are worth
zero in order for all of them to be
worth zero
that means the united states is gone
there was an atomic
bomb was dropped or something or china
took over or
whatever crazy scenario you could come
up with so
i'm not the chances i'm not worried
about that now can that s p 500 could i
put in a million dollars or a hundred
thousand dollars and then come back
four months later and it'd be worth
ninety six thousand yeah i could lose
three four thousand dollars on that 100
grand i could
uh but i i mean but i'm not gonna i'm
not worth the fdic insurance is in the
event of a bank
failure an individual bank could fail
an individual mutual fund could fail but
it's very unlikely
an individual stock investment really
could fail and be worth zero that's very
high likelihood
a much more high likelihood than
anything we're talking about but
um yeah if you want if you wanna spread
it out across banks you can do that
uh i don't i don't fool with it i just
dump it into an s p 500.
this is the dave ramsey